the important people are here so I can
start
is that is that the message here
good afternoon I'm Billy Hollis
uh developer turn designer started
writing code for money in 1978 if you
can imagine that some of you aren't
alive you will not I bet
I spend my time mostly helping teams
teams of developers usually that have
decided to start leveraging design and
design thinking what I started doing
this back in 2008 uh almost no
development teams were doing anything I
would really recognize
as ux design but that has changed over
the years
as William Gibson said the future is
here it's just not evenly distributed
you might find yourself somewhere along
this path here
most teams start out doing fairly simple
things like visual design getting
getting the Aesthetics right I still run
into teams though that are just throwing
walls of data grids at their users so
that still absolutely does happen but I
see teams kind of moving through this
set of of possibilities uh but because
they are still trying to find their way
in many cases they're still learning how
to do it there are there's certainly the
possibility for failing at design
because you're new at it and that's what
this session is about to maybe help you
avoid some approaches now I understand
why teams haven't made as much progress
maybe yes we might ideally like for them
to in ux design it's not as if you don't
have a lot of other things to worry
about now is it
you've got the cloud you got AI you got
devops and and I breach every other week
and in addition to those problems
another hold up in getting to a good
place in design is that developers tend
to be rather code Centric
and as a result they uh they they prefer
writing code almost over almost anything
else and sometimes they'll just
basically blow off
all the other things that they really
ought to do in order to get back to
writing code
so I really get that and the result that
comes from that though and the reason
why you ought to have somebody on your
team that sort of understands the
importance of design and tries to get
good at it
the uh is because if you don't you'll
run into design failures there are lots
of those out there lots of lots of
examples of them I like to start out
with this one because it's a trillion
dollar project
that arguably failed
partially because of design
trillion dollars now that's
I like to put that in context for people
who don't use US Dollars that's one and
a half polands
in terms of that's the one and a half
times the GDP of Poland that was spent
on this aircraft program that so far has
produced about 700 planes
and
I think that much money
you think okay they got this right
didn't they I mean how could anybody
spend that much no other government
of course they messed up and this
article summarizes a lot of the reasons
why and you're welcome to go look at
this if you like
um there are there are various ways that
they failed
um one of them was that the architecture
of code was done very poorly
and I I won't talk about that here but
if you are interested in architecture
here's the here's the book you want you
want to read for that writing software
by Yuval Loi but the main things that
they did that really worked out very
poorly from my perspective
it is that's just almost excusable it's
poor ux design because per ux design can
absolutely lead to catastrophic results
and and a program that big with life and
death on the line
Whenever Whatever Whenever a some a
pilot steps into that plane it's kind of
unforgivable so here is one of the
extracts from that article that
discusses where the design went wrong
and I don't normally like reading from
slides but in this case it's a big
enough deal that I'll make an exception
the fighter jet also suffers from a
slightly embarrassing touch screen
problem
after making switch from hard flip
switches to touch screens
just keep it on down touch screens in
the plane don't work 20 percent of the
time says one at 35 pilot
well
look at the layers of failure that are
involved here that they put these things
in place they didn't understand the
psychology of the user they didn't
understand the value of tactile switches
no they sat around in a meeting one day
and said oh this it's probably helpful
to remember when this is this is when
the iPhone was taking over the world
when a lot of this design was done
so I'm sure they're sitting there with
their brand new iPhones
and going ah touch screens for the
future they're programmable look at all
the things we can do to upgrade the
fighter jet over time if we don't have
mechanical switches
okay I mean this is this is a stock
photo of course but it's some it's how I
imagine the meeting went now
to avoid that kind of failure
if you're a developer team you need to
do something some developer teams are
good at but let's be honest about it
some of them are not and that is to put
yourself in the mind of the user
I mean I want you right now to close
sort of close your eyes or stare off in
the distance and visualize fighting
flying a fighter jet
and I want you to think all this all the
distractions that you might engage not
to mention the fact that you your life
might be on the line
with a tenth of a second reaction time
now think about turning something on and
the physical difference between hitting
a touchscreen button which you do lots
of times every day and flipping a
mechanical switch
just think about that difference there
and think about the potential risk that
comes from that I mean Pilots really
can't afford a 20 failure rate on
flipping a switch
that's just ridiculous
now to put yourself in kind of a a
comparable not nearly as dangerous
situation what would happen if one of
your users thought they'd entered an
order but the software didn't think it
happened if that happened regularly in
your software what would be the
ramifications for your team would that
be considered acceptable by your
business
absolutely not
so why did they do that well as they're
sitting there in that meeting that I
visualized I'm thinking because this was
the iPhone era and this is the new
technology that somewhere along the line
the phrase was uttered wouldn't it be
cool if
we did touch screens in the in the
fighter jet
and I consider that a huge red flag when
I teach design classes mostly to
developers I really focus on considering
with that when they hear that phrase
they ought to step back now not all cool
things should be rejected as
something to fold into a new design but
y'all ought to always make sure
that you're not doing it primarily
because it's cool
and that it does in fact fit the
circumstances which in this case those
cool touch screens do not
so be careful of that as you go through
I I try to teach developers not to do
that the result may look absolutely cool
but if it doesn't accomplish the
purposes to which the project was
dedicated then it's um it the coolness
doesn't help doesn't make up for the
fact that that prop that there's there's
a severe problem there
now sometimes and I don't want you to do
this either
but when when that much money has been
spent the excuses started to pour out
one of the generals this is a direct
quote in that article from The General
you don't drive your Ferrari to work
every day you only drive it on Sundays
this is our high-end fighter we want we
don't want to use it on the low end
fight
well what if you created a Next
Generation app
and it was really cool it had all the
latest Technologies in it it looked very
modern but it was clunky it was so
ill-suited to what the users do on a
routine basis the most important things
they do that they they it slowed them
down
or made them ineffective in other ways
so uh you're talking to the person who
signed the check and you say well
um this is our Ferrari level app and
it's not intended to be used every day
after he's already spent all the money
on it how far is that going to get you
with him
that's pretty ridiculous isn't it so I I
just I looked at this thing and wondered
what these people should have done well
first of all they should have had a
world-class architect the article that I
reference talks a lot about the the code
difficulties and the bugs that came out
of that something like eight times the
code of the fighter jet
um generation preceding it and very
buggy but they also needed a world-class
designer uh they needed to to not to not
do the overuse of the cool stuff uh and
they needed to really spend a lot more
time to understand and aim at the
intended user the pilot
and unless you think this is just kind
of a one-off thing I actually had
on a much smaller scale an example from
one of my clients that did a
browser-based app for order entry of and
um and and hooking up expedited freight
happened to be the the domain
they've been using this as400 app for
years this was supposed to replace it
they rolled it out and it was so much
slower for a user to get the order done
that the users rebelled and said no
stick our is-400 back in here we are not
going to because they're they were paid
on commission you see
those people had a vested interest in
getting the orders done as quickly as
possible it's money in their pockets
so the browser-based app was jumped and
the product and the uh the project was
started all over again now when I looked
at the at the browser-based app it had
all the modern cool browser stuff
too hard and slow to use
it didn't fit the flow of what those
people did when they got expedited
freight orders into the system so it was
jumped
oh you want to see an example from
Microsoft Microsoft has if you're going
to talk about bad design you'll be able
to find an example for Microsoft
somewhere
and I'm known but the I mean I I know a
lot of people at Redmond I get up to
campus quite often and I'm kind of
considered by some of them to be the
crank who's always pointing out now you
got this wrong I've been doing that for
20 years now and
um some of them don't even listen to me
anymore but
some of the ones that do so keep doing
it Billy it does keep us on our toes uh
let's talk about uh something from
Microsoft called Story remix for how
many of you does that ring a bell
one person
it was in the Keynote
at Microsoft build
in 2017. now do you understand that
build is where they roll out their
newest stuff that's supposed to have a
huge impact
on their customer base
so this was in the keynote what does
Story Remix do well basically
uh the demo that was in the keynote was
exerting inserting explosions into Home
Videos
they had a video of a sucker
team like middle schoolers and somebody
kicked the ball into the net and it
exploded when it went in the net that
was the demo
you probably think I'm joking I'm going
to show it to you right now
sorry I had all everything closed and
some of you know I had a bullish screen
it caused me to have to reload a bunch
of stuff okay I've got a little
animation here I'm going to open it with
the photos app
it would by default go to movies and TV
you ever seen these uh these reloading
animations that are kind of from games
except that they're really kind of to be
funny this is like a gun that bites the
ammo
when it reloads
all right well let's uh let's put an
explosion into it now you have to know
where this is
because it's like they spent all that
money and they're not going to throw it
away
even though that nobody wants it or
needs it
so what you have to do is go to first of
all let's get this thing
sort of at the point that it needs to be
where they've just fire stop where
they've just fired a bullet right about
there I think I may not be exactly right
but you'll get you'll get the idea here
and if we start walking down the menus
there's the edit more
add 3D effects right here
and since I had to reboot from the blue
screen oh it came up good I had I had
one time earlier when I was practicing
that it did not
so oh no I guess I have to also kind of
position it here so we do it just at the
point where okay yeah there you can see
where I fired so I'm going to put the
explosion just at the point of firing so
something like that see this explosion
right here
I'll put it where I think the bullet
ought to go something like this
you ready
so now back to the beginning
okay look this is this is fun and I'm
sure a middle schooler could could
occupy himself herself for however long
putting explosions in videos that they
take on their their phone I I completely
concede that point but this is supposed
this
build at that point we would have a
keynote with four five thousand people
in a giant Hall watching the keynote up
on stage
and they they put explosions in videos
as part of the keynote so that's a
pretty extreme case of wouldn't it be
cool if
I mean nobody really needed this but
maybe middle schoolers
um certainly normal Windows users
absolutely did not
um and it's a complete waste of
development dollars so
that's that that's an example of
trying to be too cool and very often one
of the causes of that is you move to a
new platform and you want to use the
stuff that's on it many of you are
probably doing
software today on platforms for example
that don't really support animation
effectively if you have older HTML or
you have something like Windows forms or
some of the Java toolkits from 15 years
ago you you can't really do animation so
one of the things I see teams do is to
go when they go to animations
they just go crazy with them
I had a a story I like to tell about
this because
I work in uh the desktop world mostly
native software development and I was
working with a client in uh that did a
software package
evaluating their user experience
and I saw that they they put in a page
flipping animation
right there was a little section with
some information and when you switch to
another page it would flip over to the
side now that is the sort of thing
that is cool the first time you see it
and boy do you get tired of it in a
hurry just like these
dancing things here are these a lot of
animations animation has a very short
time span before it becomes tedious
so I walked up to the screen and pointed
at the page flipping animation and said
don't do that
and everybody in the room laughed except
for the president of the company
because it was his idea
to put the page flipping animation in
but he and I became good friends he he
turned out to be really good at it so
that's one example of of where you can
go you can be getting get into trouble
by trying to be too cool
and of course if you want to talk about
design failures including this problem
as well as a bunch of others there's
windows 8.
I I watched Windows 8 rolled out on
stage at build 2011. and immediately
went oh this is gonna fail so hard
and I tried telling some Microsoft
people and they did not want to hear it
and I'll explain why here in just a
minute
fortunately one of the foremost
usability ux design people in the world
is Jacob Nielsen are you familiar with
him the Nielsen Norman group in Europe
and he wrote an article summarizing all
the stuff I would like to tell them and
uh of course we we now know at the end
of the day that Windows 8 was a failure
and some of us understood why because
some of us understood why it was a
preventable failure the team that was
doing it got into the the the the
trying to make it cool like the iPad was
cool because understand that a lot of
the motivation behind Windows 8 was that
the iPad was just taking over the world
at that time while they were creating it
and Microsoft was worried that Apple was
going to do to them what they did to IBM
make everything they did obsolete by
moving to an entirely new platform the
fact that the iPad really was never
going to get there that they didn't
really really get that I mean I I bought
an iPad in 2010 to understand the new
technology the new interaction patterns
and people ask me what do you know what
do you think of the iPad my grandma
loves her iPad and I know yes and your
three-year-old likes her speaking spell
too but neither of them have any work to
get done
and that was what Microsoft missed
tablets are fine mostly for consuming
and for light creation of things
creating live emails and such
but Microsoft's entire customer base was
people who get work done to make the
economy work
so they and they completely missed that
they they were they were another example
of really not listening to the user and
not understanding what the user's needs
were
and then there's another problem with it
they they wanted it to be cool oh they
saw they separately wanted it
to be cool and they could they could
tell you all the design things they put
in that they considered modern and cool
the problem with that is and you know
this you went to I there's probably
somebody in your high school
hopefully not you uh who had this
problem they tried so hard to be cool
but if you try to be cool
you're almost certainly gonna fail at it
that's just the nature of being cool
and so what we ended up with was this
operating system that was basically
trying to wave a flag look how cool I am
I'm look at me
and and with horrible design flaws
such as the page where all the apps were
now this this was just horrible I
understand there were no folders
in Windows 8. if it hadn't been for the
search box in the upper right this would
have been completely useless because
nobody would have bothered scanning
through to try to find the app that they
wanted but this is bad enough and it's
bad because we can identify the reason
there's a fundamental design principle
design principles being things that that
concern how the brain and visual system
work that determine what people are
going to understand and like and what
they're not
One Design principle is Hicks law it's
common sense though really
that the longer the list of stuff you
have to choose from the longer it's
going to take you to find the thing you
want now there's a you know mathematical
equations they kind of check how much
the Delta is if you add more stuff but
the essential
nature of hicks law is just that you
slow people down when you add things so
this was obviously a bad idea
so
didn't they get some you use your
feedback well yes they did
but they there's two things about this
problem that I want to illustrate as
their mistakes so that you hopefully
will not repeat some of what they did
yeah
they got user feedback but obviously
they didn't do it very well because
Windows 8 was so quickly
uh just slammed when it made itself into
the market
with good user feedback they would have
known what was going to happen and and
hopefully made adjustments but they
didn't
uh and that's a that's a common problem
when technologists just are so convinced
that what they produced is cool of
course everybody will like it and they
don't really get that the rest of the
population is not as lit up by cool as
we are
somebody didn't get that so why did the
feedback go wrong ah let me tell you
there's a famous story that illustrates
what the problem there is and this is
something that every development team
should understand as a principle to be
careful when you try to go get user
feedback
anybody heard of clever Hans
you know clever okay so and you you've
seen it too for those of you who want to
know a lot more about clever Hines
there's a nice Wikipedia article on it
where I got this picture right here
clever Hans was a horse that toured
Europe uh 100 120 years ago and clever
Hans could do arithmetic
seriously you bring out Clara Hines and
Hans what is three plus five
and Hans would begin stamping his foot
and he would stamp eight times
and he would stop
you can do arithmetic
well
some people got suspicious and they took
the Handler away thinking the handler
was signaling highs
but Hans could still do it
and then what they did
good suspicious experimenter they asked
Hans the question took everybody that
that knew the question that knew the
answer out of the room and put other
people in
and now Hans just keeps on stamping
what was Hans doing originally
well it turned out that the crowd would
tense up a little bit when he began to
stamp will he stamp enough
will he get to the right answer and then
when he did
they would almost imperceptibly relax
and that's what Hans was picking up on
Hans learned what people wanted
from their body language
well if a horse can do it
you think a human being can do it too
when you go to solicit feedback we are
social animals and people are tuned to
pick up your preferences and in many
cases if there's no great
cost one way or the other they'll
reflect back to you what they believe
you want to hear whether it's really
their opinion or not
and so people who are getting user
feedback learn to keep their body
language neutral for example and don't
don't give people the feedback that
tells them what you want to hear
so that was one of the big problems with
Windows 8 is that yeah they did user
feedback but Microsoft was really new at
all this stuff at the time and I really
didn't know how to do it
let's talk about another bad design
approach
assuming a design that works in one
place will also work in another
see what this does is cause teams to
copy designs
they've seen a design that seemed to
work well in some other venue
and they go well why should we go to the
trouble of creating our own design we
can just go get that one and copy that
well there's nothing wrong with that if
the domains are overlapping enough
that the design that worked over there
will also work for you
but in many cases that's not the case at
all because a good design and the better
it is the design is the more this is
likely to be true a good design is
optimized for a particular set of
circumstances
it isn't it isn't a good design in and
of itself it's a good design for that
purpose
and your purpose needs to match it or it
won't be a good design for you
so we ran into this back with one of the
first applications that that my team
produced we did an app back in 2008
for temporary staffing
and it was used it was used by Microsoft
as their demo app for you know the WPF
platform that came out at that time that
was their demo app for WPF for several
years they didn't have a lot of examples
of business apps with some interesting
Innovative sort of design we pushed the
we pushed the limits for 2008. this was
this was pretty Advanced and it was
copied literally thousands of times
because there were videos of it on the
web and it was one of the few there well
one of the companies that copied it
was 3M
who does a radiology reporting app now
this app is for temporary staffing sales
people
to match up temporary employees with
temporary jobs
this app is for Radiologists to create
Radiology reports just how much overlap
is there between
those two sets of circumstances so they
copied staff links it failed and they
called us and of course it failed it was
pretty on just aren't sales people so we
went up and helped them design this this
is 2010. and we help them design this
app and what we what we did was was
go back to sort of a blank sheet
approach just like we did with with that
temporary staffing app and try to come
up with ways to make it Innovative using
these new technologies not cool now I
don't really think this app looks that
cool
but it was highly Innovative why well
because
starting fresh you can question
assumptions
for for helping how things work and and
I vividly remember the meeting in which
this assumption was questioned because
we were looking at how users how doctors
create these Radiology apps today they
normally dictate
or sometimes they select options that
would insert text into the report and
the report looked more or less like it
was produced on a selectric typewriter
because the original reports from
dictation were done that way and the
automated versions up to that time were
just basically
automated versions that produce the same
kind of report
my question was oh I guess I should talk
about this because you may not know how
how Radiology reports work the doctor
says oh he sees something in an image
and he says ah yes in the upper medial
left they have a whole language to
describe where in the image they're
talking about
and the question I asked was what
instead of all that why can't we just
grab a piece of the image
and stick it in the Radiology report
because we got the technology to do that
now five years ago we really didn't
practically but now we do because we
have to sell a new wave of technology
and I remember
I remember the looks on the face two
doctors in the room as well as a whole
bunch of developers and they go
yeah I I guess there's no rules or laws
or anything I guess we could do that and
that turned out to be the feature that
caused that
system to move from a second tier player
to a top tier player like so was it 400
million in the first five years
and that screenshot that you saw is
about the only screenshot you'll find on
the web because they don't like their
competitors to see it
to get too much of an idea of of the uh
of the design so
there's a difference between cool and
Innovative this app was Innovative
because it questioned assumptions and
came up with a better way of thinking
about things
some people might have looked at that
and go oh that's cool I can certainly
imagine a doctor looking oh that's cool
but as I said cool isn't necessarily bad
in and of itself it's whether or not it
fits what the user needs and that
becomes kind of the defining feature of
that app
here's another bad design approach
laziness
is regrettably common
let's Show an example that many of you
have probably heard of even though you
may not have seen the actual screen
how many of you heard about the nuclear
alert the nuclear Alert in Hawaii oh
five or six years ago when the entire
Island was told that the missiles were
coming
well here's the screen where that guy
made the
made the mistake
this is like
I don't know no design at all really
and understand that this software is to
be used in emergencies
now one of the basic principles of
design is when people are going to get
distracted you have to do an extra good
job of design remember the pilots
in the f-35s your responsibility goes up
instead somebody just throws some stuff
on a web page
okay this is awful and there's no excuse
for it really because I sat down and and
roughed out an interface in Microsoft
Word in three minutes
that would prevent you from making that
mistake a very very high percentage of
the time
and all I did was kind of put in some
spacing
and add a little colored label there
this is not a drill
in sort of red to tip off people see the
reddish colors
the the our brain is culturally
programmed to think that there that
that's a potential problem potential
danger so design principles use things
like that to keep people from making
mistakes so laziness
it it happens all over the place the uh
among a lot of Developers
there is an attitude
that if I just make it work man it
didn't work last month so
I'm I'm done I've done my I've done my
job because it's possible to do this
thing that couldn't be done before
well here's the kind of problem that
that leads to does uh does this mean
anything to any of you
well it didn't mean anything to the
maintenance guy at the Notre Dame
Cathedral either
when when it popped up on the alarm
system
and by the time he figured out what it
meant and they got to the place that it
told them was a problem
the place was was in the process of
almost burning to the ground
so
no design at all that's that's extreme
laziness not I mean it would have been
some work but but gosh how hard would it
have been to sort of take that and put
some text up to go with it
developers also tend to um
tend to get into some some bad design
areas by designing what appeals to them
as opposed to what's right for the users
I'm particularly hard on the wall of
data grids pattern not because I think
data grid should never be used there are
circumstances where they're the best
option
an example would be certain Financial
type interfaces
it should be in a data grid that's the
natural way that's the way the
accountants think
but in general
data grids tend to be used because
they're easy you just set them up and
tell them what data goes in let the
users figure out how to sort and move
the columns
that's the easy lazy way to do it
and it appeals to us because what that
does as developers is now we don't
really have to understand the user's job
that well
we know they need all we need is to
figure out what Columns of data they
need for their job we don't have to
figure out how they're using it
so we find the columns they need we
throw it in a data grid we stick that on
the screen and then they have to put up
with that problem for however many years
that they use the system it slows them
down
um and then another other place that
laziness tends to crop up
and I kind of understand this one
because the Technologies to fix this
easily are fairly new
but that is
if a user comes up and says man I'm a
power user and I have to have this field
right here nobody else cares
so what do you do he just I mean he's
not going to give up until you until
you've given this data so you stick
another data field on the screen
and now let's multiply that by how many
dozens
is this a is this a familiar
scenario for you what do you end up with
crowded screens with all kinds of stuff
on them that most people don't need
in the modern app world we have the
ability to use templates and dynamic UI
to only show things to people that need
to see them take some extra work to do
that but it's a big payoff for the user
but you know it appeals to us to just
say okay that's the data you need then
I'll give it to you and everybody else
will have to see it too
I also see some cases even though
browser-based apps are the predominant
way of doing software now and and they
should be but there are certainly cases
where the team says well we're doing a
browser-based app just because we don't
have to worry about deployment
stick it on a web server and it's done
there are certain applications that the
robustness the speed the configurability
ETC the State Management the
multi-monitor capability capabilities of
native platforms turn out to be a much
better match than browsers
now that's a that's a small percentage
of overall apps 10 20 maybe but I do see
teams that that they're in they're
clearly in that situation but they're
they understand browser stuff they don't
want to think about the deployment
issues so they just
okay we're going to do it in a browser
then
if you hear somebody say well yeah
it's it could be better but the users
just need more training on it that's the
red flag for that particular situation
our convenience shouldn't be trumping
the user's needs
if we could double the speed of a user
by for example getting a native app and
I've seen that by the way native apps
that that
increased the speed of the user by 100
then how many more users are there than
Developers
quite a number of them so our
convenience shouldn't Trump their needs
it's not good business
for that to be the case
uh you can avoid some of these mistakes
by vetting the designs
uh anytime that you've got a
particularly radical change and
particularly when your team is
relatively naive at the whole design
process
and how to do things then you're
probably going to make mistakes and you
want to catch those mistakes early
um
and that's tricky actually part of the
reason It's Tricky is that users
existing users
have a sunk cost in the system as it
exists today
I don't care how hard it is to use
they've figured it out
and they don't realize necessarily that
there can be better designs in many
cases they won't believe that there can
be better designs until you put
something clearly better in front of
them
so that being the case they will give
you pushback during feedback and and
that you have to manage that you do want
to listen to them and you don't want to
respect you do want to respect their
their positions but you don't want users
to prevent Innovation that's really good
for the business just because they're
comfortable
with the old system
you do prototyping and usability testing
things like that depending on how many
users do you have what's the turnover
how hard is it to learn and how easy can
we make it uh those kinds of things are
become more and more important as you
build up large user bases because the
payoff for them because they do take
investment these things aren't aren't
free
they do cost time and money so you do it
when the payoff is big but one of the
easiest tricks
to try to to vet designs is that when
you're going out to design things as a
team
you don't do what most teams do today
which is to come up with one design
and show it to the users and then see
what they don't like and grind on that
for a while and then take it back and
just some people call that design
process Proto cycling
you just keep grinding you will actually
get better results faster if you come up
with multiple design possibilities to
solve a particular design issue
and now that's not necessarily easy it
becomes easier when you do it but you
just kind of put this okay this is a
perfectly acceptable design we'll put
this aside and then we'll um we'll we'll
see if we can find something better and
we find two or three or maybe even four
and then we show that to the users you
get much much better feedback
when you show people multiple designs
you ever been in that meeting where you
show well here's ours here's the screen
here's the app
and and the meeting breaks down into a
food fight over no I think that should
be above that and that should be below
that and it should be three pixels over
and I don't like the colors how many of
you have been in that meeting at one
time or another
yeah I see the I see the head knives out
there you avoid that with multiple
design possibilities because now they're
going hmm which one of these matches my
job better
that you've raised their cognitive
processing to a much higher level you've
gotten it away from minutia
so multiple design competition is a is
is a great trick there
in fact it has a it has another use in
avoiding status quo bias
true story
those are the best ones
I was working with a Fortune 500 company
in America
in transportation and I worked with six
seven different teams to redesign their
modules in the brand new system one of
the managers came to me
uh before we started on them and said I
understand you don't like data grids
well it's true I don't but I don't
necessarily borrow them I just think
there are better Alternatives and he
said well I use yours will love their
data grids
and we've I've promised them they won't
lose their data grits man that's pretty
extreme status quo bias they're already
telling you at the beginning they don't
really change anything
and this is for produce ordering it's an
order entry app
so what I said to him was well you might
be right
I know he's not but
it's okay I'll let him think that he
might be you might be right so but we
are committed to this idea of multiple
designs that compete with one another so
we'll do we'll do the grid based design
and let the users have a shot at that
but you know we'll do some Alternatives
that they can look at too for comparison
and see at this point he doesn't know
what to do
because I haven't said no but I haven't
said yes either
and a lot of managers at that level are
kind of used to getting what they want
by just stating and intimidating
well
the bottom line at the end of the day
that app was considered extremely
Innovative and it's got no data grids in
it
we came up with a much better design
than that
um other another
another approach that I would consider
a temptation
for many teams as they're getting
started in this remember
people in the developer Community would
rather be doing other things
so there is a temptation to do things
that kind of seemed like design but
there are aren't really designed I call
that design theater
so we talked about one of those asking
for feedback but tipping off the user
what you want
that's one way there
um another one is to build something
first and then get feedback without
going through really design at all
without talking to the users that much
and I'll talk about why that's bad in a
minute uh designing from assumptions
that might not be true
without without making sure those
assumptions are are correct and they do
apply meaningless phrases like
user-centric which is very overused I
try never to use that
um designing by implementing backlog
items some agile teams fall into what I
consider a trap there because the
problem with that is now the only thing
you're ever going to really design is
little pieces off the backlog and it
design of the app as a whole needs some
big picture thinking and you're not
going to get to that by designing
individual features
so designing Alpha backlog I think is is
kind of design theater
um assuming design equals Aesthetics
that's that's a pretty bad one there but
uh managers are particularly susceptible
to that one I get phone calls from them
from time to time well we've about
finished this this application and we'd
like you to put a good design on it
now you're unclear on the concept here
but what he means is he wants me to
decorate it with nice Aesthetics which
actually I'm no good at I have somebody
on my team who's really good at it but I
am no good at that I I'm I'm a designer
um
so
a lot of the reasons for that as I said
is that code Centric developers do
sometimes resist embracing design
um so they'll say things like
the users don't know what they want
we have to build something to show them
they can't tell us what they want
I am indebted to Alan Cooper
I always thought this but I'm indebted
to him for the confidence to tell you
because he is one of the most foremost
interaction designers in the world
anybody know who he is
oh that's tragic how many of you use
Visual Studio
you're using Alan Cooper's work
he invented the drag and drop
development environment
for what became Visual Basic one which
is the ancestor
of today's Visual Studio
foremost interaction designer and I I
saw him speak he was doing the keynote
at an event uh at Microsoft in what
their patterns and practices group if
you remember that group
and he said this it's just a total
cop-out that you have to build something
and then show it to them if you do that
the end result will be something that's
just good enough that the users will put
up with it
it's very very unlikely that it will be
Innovative or anywhere near optimal as a
design
now it is true that users cannot design
screens that is not their job
that's not the point
users understand their jobs and their
workflow
they have to
to do it
and when somebody says the users don't
know what they want we have to build
something and show them what they're
missing is that finding out from the
users what their flow looks like
understanding their job that itself is a
skill
and they're admitting they don't have
that skill that's fine
okay at one time I couldn't
hit a baseball I couldn't
ski but I built those skills up so
it's it what their their implicit
assumption is because I can't do it
nobody can do it
and that is false
it's clearly false we got 20 years of
History to show that it's false
understanding how to get that
information out of users there's
enormous literature on this throughout
the design community
I don't mean to say it's easy but it is
a skill that can be developed and
effectively done and that's the way you
get to uh to Innovation to draw that out
of them and then design with the picture
of the user in your head
now of course as I said a lot of you
would rather be doing other things and
some of you don't really like talking to
people very much
okay I mean in fact I I've joked in the
past that some of you have a substance
abuse problem
and the substance you abuse is code
it's like you keep it's like man you got
to write that code you just have to it's
I can I can tip you off if as to
how to know if you're a code addict
you're in the meeting
where something new is being discussed
that you're going to work on the meeting
is scheduled for 90 minutes
less than 10 minutes into the meeting
you are coding the solution in your head
and no longer listening to the person
talking to you
does that sound familiar to some of you
that's the sign of an addiction you
can't put it aside it's worse than
smoking
you can't put it aside for 90 minutes
so
there's also a
a common
false
sort of sort of understanding false
conceptual understanding of what a
designer is among Developers
their concept is that the designers are
special colorful creatures
and they can do things that that the
turkey vulture developers over there
who are looking on an envy that they're
just not the same type of person and
they can't do that that's that's really
a completely false way of looking at it
90 of developers can can effectively
participate in design
so don't don't buy into this this false
idea that you can't
um now the ten percent that can't I can
tell you what they're like you know
people like this they have that mindset
that if I think it should be this way
then I don't understand how anybody else
could prefer something different
you know people like that
well we all do right those people suck
at design and the reason why it's pretty
clear isn't it they can't put themselves
in the mind of the user
every user should think just like them
as far as they're concerned so there are
developers that can't design but they're
a very small minority and I say this
having trained literally thousands of
developers over the last 15 years
so it it it you you can do much better
than you think
another bad approach as I said that the
build but and then get feedback is uh is
certainly a problem
um sometimes I hear this stated as we
have to rapidly build the MVP we have to
do an MVP and we have to get it out
quickly and we'll iterate and refine to
a good design I have never seen that
work
to produce a good design it has the same
problem I talked about earlier the
design will iterate until it's
acceptable and the users don't gripe
about it too much and then
the iteration will stop
and it's really hard to even get to a
good design because you're typically
starting with something it's really bad
and you put it out in production and now
you got status quo bias because people
eventually figured that part out it's
just a bad bad approach
to design your UI by throwing something
into an MVP
and the thing about it is a lightweight
design face does not take that long
for modest size projects week or two
bigger projects three or four weeks
designing from assumptions why did
Microsoft do this in Windows 8.
foreign
they researched
iPad users
and they discovered an interesting fact
that a large percentage of them 80 to 90
percent
did not understand the concept
of a hierarchical file folder set
and you know people like this the ones
that have a desktop that's nothing but a
giant block
of of application shortcuts
they don't understand file folders or it
just doesn't naturally work for them so
Microsoft started Windows 8 with the
assumption that folders are where apps
go to die if we put absent if we put
apps and folders people just won't use
them because that's we're competing with
the iPad now well that is true in the
iPad world but that assumption did not
hold in the windows world how many
windows users what percentage of Windows
users don't get file folders
there are some but there aren't many
and file folders are so enormously
useful that people that do understand
them won't put up without them
I talked a little bit about the
uh this earlier but I'm not going to hit
this a little bit harder the idea that
um
that people think oh well if I get the
Aesthetics right then that's a good
design
um and this I hate to say this because I
I I'm I admire visual designers who can
create a certain feel and get colors
right and some of the things I can't do
that
so I admire them but when they take that
and try to sort of pitch the idea that
that is design
well I I that's a that's a false
equivalence to me
um but it's appealing from the expect
from the Viewpoint of developers in many
cases because it gives developers an
excuse to delegate
the design I'll get a visual designer do
that now I don't have to worry about
design
I'll get back doing my my rest API or
whatever
Aesthetics are important
but they're only a small part of design
I mean you do want an app to have a good
first impression people will uh people
will naturally give the app more
credibility and value in their heads if
it does have a good first impression and
good Aesthetics the problem is the
Aesthetics can't cover up
a really bad design
the Cosmetics can only take you so far
so you've seen quite a number of
failed design approaches which I'm going
to summarize here in just a moment how
much time do I have left about five six
minutes
so I I want to talk just a bit about the
different levels of design effort
because some of the some of the problems
come up differently and problems have
more impact and more uh they they lose
you more money as you move up the scale
so certainly applying graph layout and
graphic aesthetic design does is more
valuable does increase the value over
the no design situation
but that's by no means the the uh the
only way that design can be leveraged
you can also see going up to
a standalone design where you take
pieces of an existing app
and redesign it data visualizations
better search or a lot of apps have
awful awful search
that's a that's that's a step up you
aren't replacing a whole app but you are
trying to fix some of the most important
pieces of it
and then you move to that from that up
to interaction design
where it's typically an entire
application or at least a big part of it
and you're all you're worried about
things like navigation between the
pieces the interaction of the pieces and
so that's a step up in terms of the
design you worry about
and about half a dozen times in my
career I've had to do design across
parts of the organization multiple
applications that have to coordinate
with one another I tend to call that
design thinking we're applying design
thinking because we're typically
changing business workflows across the
organization when we do that
so I mean that's a whole that's a long
way from doing layout and and colors and
Graphics in it so there's this entire
spectrum of different kinds of design
effort that you can do you should kind
of understand where you are the higher
you go up that up that ladder the more
it will cost the more time you will
invest the more value you'll get the
more the risk is
and the more you need outside help I
mean you can probably do some of the
stuff down here by yourself you can try
it what's the cost if you fail not that
big but the higher up that that ladder
you go the more the cost of failure
means that getting somebody to help you
is helpful
I will say though that um if you are up
in those those higher those those top
two tiers there you can get some pretty
incredibly High payback I'm not going to
go through this in in detail because you
can do this yourself and I will make you
an offer if your company is interested I
will get on a virtual visit with you and
and walk through a spreadsheet that
helps calculate the return on investment
for design in those higher more complex
phases
and it's and it bases that estimate on
how many users do you have how much do
they use the app a day how much can we
speed them up how much do we pay them it
takes those factors and then rolls them
all in and we've seen
real cases where our clients saved tens
of millions a year
with just with better design now that's
admittedly large user basis but saving
tens of millions a year when
the whole design effort didn't cost a
million dollars is that's a that's
pretty impressive return on investment
so there's the link for that
there's a Excel version and there's a
Google Sheets version that you can grab
grab a copy of and work with if you like
and as I said you can you can ping me
and I will uh I'll help you walk through
it if you like so let's summarize those
bad design approaches
doing no design at all yeah okay copying
and Design
by the way I'll take questions as I'm
going through the review if any of this
sort of makes you think of a question
you had
um designing for the convenience of the
development team
users don't know what they want yeah
well develop the skill to figure it out
don't just give up
um wouldn't it be cool if red flag
as soon as you hear it make sure that
you're not doing something just for the
coolness
design theater
getting the feedback you want by sort of
pushing the users nudging them the way
you want assuming design equal good
Aesthetics and don't fall into the we
have to build something to show them
instead some of the durable effective
design practices include focusing on the
users
um not the technology or your
convenience
if if you understand your users and what
they want and need your chances of
design failure go down pretty
dramatically
uh keep asking questions and testing
assumptions I'll tell you a story from
that
sort of you have to kind of developed
the sensibility as you're working with
users I had this set of users they were
helping a team develop an app that was a
call center ad and what they wanted to
do was do some data visualizations for
things about the person that they're
talking to the user is talking to so
they know what question to ask them
and so we talked about several
visualizations
over the span of about 20 or 25 minutes
and they and and I got the sense after a
while and just asked the inconvenient
question that the team had never asked
themselves which is could you do an
algorithm
that would just come up with the
question you want to ask
I thought about it for a bit and said
yeah I said well then just show them the
question you want to ask
why are we worrying about all this
visualization to make it easy for them
to figure the question out it's still a
puzzle just tell them a question
and then oh yeah so ask those
inconvenient questions
um do do good evaluation do very deep
and comprehensive evaluation although
they have the F-35 people certainly
didn't do that uh and as I said focus on
the things that driver turns and I'll
I'll help you with that if you like
all right I have a plural side course on
design principles if you're interested
in taking a look if you happen to have a
plural side subscription you can spend
four hours listing in the Babel about
design principles that course is 10
years old and still generating a lot of
views I'm really surprised about that
Okay so
you can get me
I'm expensive but
you can get me to do some of these
things here but I will I do like to
spread the word about a lot of these
things so you can get a free web meeting
to discuss some of these things a recent
one that's very popular is
how can we apply ux design to a legacy
application
because that's a bigger challenge in
replacing the whole thing and doing a
complete design effort
all right we have oh gosh we're right at
time we might have but we're at the end
of the day there so so why don't we uh
only see if there's any questions one or
two maybe y'all I won't hold you along
you're welcome to come up afterwards by
the way I'm leaving
to the air for the airport pretty early
tomorrow about 7 30. so you won't see me
tomorrow grab me today if you have
anything to say to me any questions
right there
uh because we're busy designing stuff
for other people and we don't have time
to do our own
the number of people who do this in the
industry is shockingly limited
compared to the demand and yeah we talk
about that every time we get together
yeah we we ought to we ought to get our
website done and and we had it's been
five years
at least since the last time we we
refreshed it not to mention that the web
the
the hosting company had a meltdown and
lost a lot of our WordPress stuff and
I can give you my tail a walk but
basically no time we understand the
problem
anything else
right there
Design Systems Design Systems have a
place in design they help get a lot of
the the interaction patterns uh at the
granular level correct and they get the
Cosmetics correct and for especially for
corporate apps nothing wrong with using
a good design system to get the look and
feel of the app up to a professional
shorter level so I have no problem with
Design Systems they in our experience
for the complex things we get into they
never cover everything they're just kind
of that low end getting the Aesthetics
and a little bit of the interaction
right
they don't tell you what do I need to
put on the screen to accomplish this
task
they're no good for stuff like that some
behind there next
yes
oh yes senior yes well uh the in my
experience there's two kinds of senior
managers
the ones who are driven by spreadsheets
and the ones that are driven by video
okay the ones that are driven by video
you show them examples our app could
look like this the ones that are driven
by money and spreadsheets my
spreadsheets are good you're going to
get a lot of return
and of course some people kind of kind
of need both
um but it's also important for them to
understand what what you're talking
about when you say design because it's
very possible probable even that their
concept of the meaning of that word is
not close to the meaning I will describe
it to it uh they may think that it's all
about the visual aesthetic stuff
um or that it's about the fancy stuff
the animations and such when it's not so
make sure they understand what you're
talking about when you say design
all right I would love to talk about
this stuff as long as you would sit here
but I know you've had a long day and
I've kept you about five minutes longer
than uh than otherwise need be so thank
you very much you may come up and talk
to me afterwards but I've enjoyed being
with you and uh please please catch me
here or tonight uh if you have anything
else you want to discuss
thanks a lot folks